foreign
you know if I didn't love meat so much
it would be really gross watching this
this
we should send to the women in Texas
absolutely right like per size
try travel like abortions yeah Fun Size
abortions
is this a hanger or
as they say
I think you do that after you abort your
your baby it's like a it's covered in
the dead babies yeah
remember the triangle in school
yes that was um not a real instrument
and
why
why were all the band teachers the only
people that chaperone the dances
were band teachers there as chaperones
for your playing the triangle the band
teachers were just they had their hands
in a lot of Pops
[Laughter]
so you're busy today huh that you're
shoving meat in your face like this
no Whitney
I have three dogs and That Shook Me
do you oh yeah the one that your sisters
is like
that doesn't count as a dog that's rude
because you wanted him
I want the way you wanted him I want to
take a screen grab of him so I could get
put him on Instagram with his tongue
hanging out yeah I mean it's cute but
it's like
do you put something on his tongue that
so it doesn't dry
it actually stays really wet oh good
because you have to constantly do it
though so like you have to take dog's
teeth out when you have to take the
teeth out but my time just hang out it's
really cute but it dries yeah and it's
uncomfortable for them so you can even
just put like
some of your meat juice on it nut oil
it's like putting chapstick on your lips
if they're chapped yeah but what can you
put use for dogs though I'll look it up
there's a natural don't buy anything
from anyone yeah there's a natural
um free option
because you're using coconut oil as lube
right
yeah I don't I don't use any lube really
really spec
I always kind of feels off
because you're putting a spit is lube is
the number one Gateway gay it might be
gay too I don't know I'm sure oh my God
it's the last one I doubt that it's the
number one way to get a UTI because all
the bacteria in your mouth right
right spit on it
put it on your dick or my vagina and now
you're just putting bacteria inside
inside my open hole
will not be at Coachella next year
should be sad sad day when open hole
isn't around dude butthole is still a
fucking Jam that album
Celebrity Skin is that what it is uh
celebrity uh go on take everything take
everything I want you to but that's um
uh doll doll oh okay so what was the
other I mean it's on my current playlist
so why don't I just check celebrity
Violet I feel like it was Violet um well
it might have been there was definitely
a celebrity right but mine nope mine was
the one with the one that Olivia Rodrigo
got called out for possibly doing
something similar from by Courtney Love
but I don't I don't see it
um
it was the cover of the girl winning the
prom yes right yes but that is not
Celebrity Skin wait I'm confused
live through this God that's so good
this was lived through this yes that was
a great album incredible album I saw her
um Courtney at a party once oh really I
had she killed her husband yet yes she
had and she was sitting on the bar in a
teeny teeny little pink dress she was
sitting up straight with her legs wide
open okay and I died
and Creed came out between her eyes by
the way remember when sorry music there
was like two years where music was just
[Laughter]
wait what I don't know very much about
music but like I do feel like I could do
that all men loved it too because it
made them feel that they could know men
all men all match thing all men why is
there no more men all women they're all
gone well I don't see gender but okay go
back to your well all men I transl white
straight men is that more specific sure
all white straight men I feel loved that
music because it just validated them not
having to actually communicate they're
straight but also they're kind of
crooked
in their dealings yes
although you know who I do fuck with who
train
what's TR why can't I think of training
well they all sound the same in my mind
don't be distracted by got a ticket for
a runaway train
ing
[Music]
at me like do you remember the video for
that was about like sex trafficking what
it's a Soul Asylum video yes with the
little kid it was such a bummer yeah
that was a bummer he put um or whoever
the the probably the mom involves uh put
photos of lost or kidnapped kids and a
lot of them were found
from that from the music video put in
the music and less
um yes they put a bunch of photos of
missing children teenage girl uh girls
and boys and stuff that were kidnapped I
feel like there's a lot of that in their
entertainment now that we're looking
back we're finding a lot of that a lot
of people were a lot of artists were
trying to go just do the right thing you
know like find these kids instead of
making a music video where we're just
putting like whipped cream on women's
tits yes they like they didn't have to
do that like they were like the real
ones I mean it's kind of corny like
they're you know
there's so much meat in your teeth right
now
um yeah there's always been me in my
teeth my gums are in between each one
there's a lot in there I feel like
there's a whole snack in there I need to
get back to using that cocoa floss I
don't think they're sponsors anymore but
they're a good company and that's how
you know they're not paying me to say
this is there is there bad and good
floss yes
why do you hate Turtles
is there fly okay there's floss is
killing Turtles I don't have enough time
there's biodegradable floss you just
have to do it really fast before 500
Degrees before it doesn't do its job and
it gives you more my favorite is when
like assholes are like these paper
straws are the worst
because they like gets off so fast just
drink faster
yeah that's a way to do it also aren't
we drinking it out of plastic cups
what's yeah but
paper straws and plastic cups grow up
your inability
to tolerate discomfort it's true but my
seven dollar smoothie it's the Shaw's
gonna I'm just gonna get soggy okay then
take the top off and finish the rest
like this
that always gives me a brain free
fucking
um Junior agent
intelligence
you fuck you fucking
nepotism baby that works at Fox
I brought something I told you I was
going to bring something
camera one so this is a this is my mom
she's no longer with us hey Jessie she's
here now hey Jessie
you're not on camera oh shit okay it's
nothing recording this we're not even
recording so just real quick
um Jesse did wear this bra today
I did and I you know that had been my
favorite bra but it's so funny because
before coming here I'm like God
underwires are so annoying yeah
that's a it's called a thread many of
those make up the block right you're
hanging by one
okay so what brand is this hmm probably
Tarjay
um I'm gonna guess Target
it looks like a Target bra uh-uh hold on
I can't it's all I mean I wear it
I wear it to bed
it's real
but the underwire is old huh I'm I'm in
your shirt and your bra this is how
Cults start by the way
you come over to someone's house next
thing you know you're wearing the shirt
the bra and the dog is licking you
does that feel good
is this the new like way we're getting
equality
feels very feminist of you
um pro-feminism I feel like this could
be a good like like a bird feeder
the reason Jesse made paluso is here
today is not because why else would I
have her here because she's funnier than
me uh except to talk about
um do you work for that company are they
paying you I'm thirsty bitch you're just
like there used to be a thousand drinks
on the table I know I don't know where
the hell they all went all the drinks
only go on the table if they are
paying us and pay their own employees
all right let's move it so so we both
have two dead parents we do we're both
orphans no we're not we it's worse their
parents loved us but they died yeah
that's true that part's true at least we
had love I love when people say that
well at least you parent at least you
had love yeah but they're not here
anymore
have you felt the thing maybe not where
you hear about people's parents that are
like 92 doing laps around the high
school track that are healthy sounds
like a pedophile why do why would anyone
go to a high school that's not going to
high school old people go there and take
laps that's true but they also go to the
mall they do they go to places where
kids used to be fine I if you cannot run
the old pedophile like you're gonna die
anyway yeah our old people of all
pedophiles because they're exercising at
places I think to them if you're 90 and
you're a pedophile you'd be into someone
that was like 40. have you speaking of
90 in a pedophile which is not really
but might as well be have your I'm sure
you have Cosby's gonna go back on tour
yeah I volunteer okay so thank you for
bringing that up you're welcome I
volunteer to open for him
I'm volunteering to open for Bill Cosby
on the road I will open for him and the
only thing I will charge is that I will
pay you fifty thousand dollars a show
call the agent I need to do my list hold
on
age do you think I could get that gig
are we being too loud
going somewhere
uh yeah we haven't started recording
imagine me talking to anyone not for
public consumption so Grace real quick
let me run this by you Grace used to
work in uh comedy touring Department
um and uh I I stole her there's makeup
where where isn't it
I like it
you look like what my niece tries to do
makeup you see it's really cute
yeah you look like my niece Karina she
comes out she's like is it pretty
oh
okay this is gonna
I know I don't have botox anymore look
how look how like it looks great yeah
man it's real so I love the movement
right yeah I know you people actually
read mine it's like I do have laugh
lines I have laughed before thank you
Pat let me ask you a question so real
quick just running it by you um Grace uh
uh is producing on the only fans thing
now um
Bill Cosby's going back on tour do we
know who his agent is booking agent I
who who would rep him still um he's
probably just okay is he just making
phone calls I would like to open for him
on the road as his opener
and I'm going my
[Laughter]
podcast is done by the way from the left
field in the yellow pants
came a singer no I don't need a good
night's sleep because I was just uh
prescribed a hundred milligrams of
Seroquel so I'll give them to bills I'm
like just use bill just like use these
to Bill also like this is not the time
to say this but he is a rapist and I
will stop this
um uh I will I got I'm on it
um hey hey hey like I'm gonna oh like
you know what I mean I just want like
I'm gonna be like hey like I'll do the
fat out I like I will do my whole set
talking about his career and how great
he is at comedy
um and uh
so he's a rapist and he raped a bunch of
people yes is he better than anyone
comedy but can I ask you one question uh
I would say he's more successful at the
latter he does comedy in order to
procure like I mean yeah he's good yeah
he's good at doing benign comedy so
people think he's a nice guy so people
take great sleeps and then they go yeah
I'll just come to your room but like
this guy's harmless he's Mr Rogers right
and by the way he's famous like he would
never need to uh he could fuck anyone
consensually whenever he wanted so what
a great cover to look like the nice guy
Jello yeah Jello anyone that's like that
nice guy I'm like I don't know man yeah
why are you wearing a shirt that says
feminist
yep who'd you buy that from for 80. what
male designer
fucking made the feminist shirt that you
just bought to fuck girls in yoga h m
hm maybe
so last name
it is bad it is really bad that Bill
Cosby did that and he is should still be
in jail and the fact that he's out of
jail is it's crazy
hey Kim Kardashian can you get on that
yes that's a good point didn't she get a
law professor
partnership
definitely they hand out law professor
Partnerships often can't she do this
so um
it is bad he was a rapist but
are are
um where are we on
uh do you need a big
why did anyone want to fuck him
consensually though that's probably why
you had to put a little powder in the
cocktail
you got any more meat in there you go do
you got any more meat in that Korean
Tupperware uh thank you Grace Grace was
so fucking patient by the way okay
really fucking patient what is this do
you want a burrito I can heat it up
don't no it's gonna smell like that is
that it's the best smell ever is that a
pet friendly candle
yes
let me check it
don't pet it don't pet it I'm gonna see
if it's pet friendly I see there's wax
let me see where this was made why don't
you put on your fucking pubes there's
Rules to This Milagros is this a tequila
um I don't miracle
well it's a miracle that you are still
beautiful with all that makeup on your
face oh God hold on you have to stay
with me stay with me yeah let me guess
five nations uh let's uh it's his
website nice whoa from finished
okay and so this was refreshed this is
like a new site.com
Bill Cosby
can you um also he was a football player
like if we should have always known this
I didn't know that he has an app
with apple okay great she has an app so
why why would Apple allow this app to
exist this is insane this is a part of
the problem like why why is he even able
to do it baby
it hasn't received I needed to stay here
please just stay here for me
Apple should have taken the sound this
is insane when was does it say when it
was when it was made 17 plus
I'm surprised it doesn't have enough
ratings to get reviews 17 plus is the
hours he guarantees you get of sleep
with him version
6.85.1 three years ago
wow so they were planning for when he
got out of jail
I don't know I haven't tried to download
it yet I don't know if I want to but if
you download it your phone goes to sleep
thank you everybody everybody have a
good night
[Laughter]
yes yeah the app is just your alarm
snooze button hello I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I mean I didn't realize this
was even playing okay you're here
listening to music app store
I was looking for his tour dates I can't
find any dates but but there's news
coverage what's the app called
sleepy time with Cosby Bill Cosby mobile
Roadie it's called the nap app
foreign
got it getting it downloading it oh
let's go oh my gosh install
operas in offers in-app purchases so
that's probably where you're going to
get the who who so let me tell you
something about this app don't please
don't scroll down there that's all fake
so I don't care so this hold on
about four or five people were hired to
build this app in the last two years I'd
like to know their full name yes I want
to know who took this job like you know
what I mean it's like the Balenciaga
thing when they're like a Balenciaga
the sexualized kids of course they did
but in order to shoot that there were
literally the photographer should have
been like what are we doing oh whoa I'm
sorry like the makeup person the style
like there was 15 to 20 people on that
set and none of them were like
I mean you get close to the money people
are just compliant yeah but they're you
they're they think that stylist is
getting paid more than a thousand
dollars a day is it worth it is it worth
all this to you you'll never work again
I mean people don't give a fuck that
person will never they just don't think
ahead him hold on go back can you just
go back real quick just hold on not yet
refresh the page of his website watch
how he pops up dude oh my gosh is that
what it looks like when you wake up
watch
that's what he looks like that's him
hopping up from behind the bed dude and
you're just like I love that you think
he stayed around after that you don't
think he did no I think he went home or
wherever you think he's gonna sleep next
to a fucking annoying white woman I mean
he's a narcissist I don't know what his
plans to put women asleep and rape them
do you really want
to deal with them once they wake up and
they're like why is my pussy sore why
are I like do you really want to deal
like it's not like he's gonna get a
great Cosby Episode out of it
what I can't take you seriously With
This Heart on you I know I need to get
it off I'm almost there
um uh okay
what the fuck you guys you guys I mean
there were articles saying he was going
to be on tour I I swear I read that
that's where I got it but why so okay
hey can you send hey people that publish
those articles you're fired I know stop
covering him
how is he able to even be out of jail
nobody uh yeah Fox I think released it
yeah jail probably does you know what my
guess is just like a an instinct I'm
just like I think that now that and I'd
love to know your um because we're gonna
get back to what happens when your
parents die I think something's so wild
happens your intuition just fucking
because
when your parents are alive and
especially sick so much of our bandwidth
is thinking about that and then as soon
as my mom died after and my dad had
already died oh my God no one's gonna
take me seriously people already think
I'm crazy though is this crazier than
the 12 hair colors I had no this is this
is on brand okay this is like it'd be
weird if I wasn't doing this right
now so so so
you know we're here to talk about what
happens I want to do an episode of this
show almost have my sister come but
she's not feeling well
um about what hap the things they don't
tell you about death
your parents death I don't know I can't
totally speak to brother committed
suicide Uncle fell out of a
Isadora Duncan her scarf got stuck in
the wheel of a car Jesus it choked her
like I don't know like that's just
that's above my pay grade but I know if
so my um do you want to say your parents
history and you don't have to yeah I'm
open about it no I actually need a
pillow oh yeah for my back is that about
this one oh thanks yeah yeah take the
Nancy pillow thank you so much yeah yeah
just don't fart on my mom
quiff that's okay okay
go what what did you want to ask about
my dad no I just wanted I was just gonna
admit my dad had a stroke the year that
I had the two sitcoms get picked up when
everyone was like she's fucking gets
everything overnight her life is so
awesome and easy
um both my parents had Strokes without
health insurance if that's an important
thing because we're going to talk about
the things you need to confront your
parents about soon as in they need to
get their health insurance in order
their will in order shit we'll get a
medical directive all that doesn't
matter so both my parents had Strokes
with no health insurance no will no
medical directive and I didn't find out
till later but like kind of no money
it's a disaster people don't realize how
expensive
most diseases are it just that whole
process towards the end which means then
you're gonna spend the money anyway so
why don't you spend it earlier in your
life on
food healthier food yes so it that'll
cost you more now but less later I think
no I think you're right but it is we did
talk about that like how
how much it costs you know about the
mental and physical drain like you know
the the cost um the ICU with no health
insurance most the first one I was at
was sixty thousand dollars a day
and that's just one item that's one
that's one item and by the way if your
parents have strokes or whatever
um
if they call an ambulance you're gonna
get an invoice later for eight thousand
and it keeps accruing yeah and it keeps
growing and then you try to pay it and
they're like we don't take this card and
you're like what like you can't even
it's just like
it's a scam also most people don't pay
it so the people that maybe paid a
little they're gonna fucking go after
harder because they know you know when
you go in the emergency room the first
thing they ask is what can you afford
this
and and no the answer is always no no
one can by the way the answer is no I
had like a procedure done in my boob a
simple procedure yeah 15 grand
can you tell me what it was I had a bio
it wasn't an augmentation I had a biopsy
I had a little
like a chest little
you had a like a cyst you had a um a
benign cyst yeah but you did it didn't
look the scan made it look
questionable so the doctor's like well I
need to do it well they could have gone
in with a needle they did and it didn't
do what they wanted it to do because
when you go in with the needle who is
this doctor the the you probably didn't
need the surgery which is what annoys me
well when he went in usually when you go
into these little cysts if if they're
benign they'll flatten they'll just kind
of go down and this one just was like
hey I'm here I'm chilling and this is
off of the science from three years ago
because all science is three years late
right well yeah I guess I got some old
boob science yeah well that cost me 14
Grand just to check to make sure
so merry Christmas everybody mom's dead
dad's dead no one's coming back and part
of my boob is missing they went in took
part of my boob
s did you at least give me money by the
way did you at least get to keep the
tumor I wish the fact that they don't
let so if they're gonna go I'm gonna cut
this thing off your body that may or may
not have cancer in it
um what is that is that it I can see
something through your shirt oh that's
the new bra we took no this is your bra
what what is it no it's just I said it
like we'll tighten it I just saw like a
bump and I was like is that it no this
is what you threw me in when I got here
so let's say I have a benign tumor and
the doctor's like you need to take this
out but it's benign okay if it was
um malignant if it wasn't um uh what's
the word malignant yeah it was dangerous
why wouldn't you just start chemo right
this second
well because they got to make sure you
can
have some sort of proof of being able to
pay for something don't they they need
some sort of collateral I thought don't
you have to sign paperwork
you can't just like get something done
you could at least suggest it yeah that
would be the right way to do it so we
don't do things the right way so hey
Jessie you might have a tumor that's
pre-cancerous
yeah I'm like zap this sucker out let's
go okay great let's just start chemo in
case
and then we're gonna find out but the
fact that you're not trying to actually
solve the long-term problem is weird to
me right especially when you can just
add it to the tab but also don't you
want don't you want to add more to the
tab doc medicine is also they call it a
practice
because they're practicing which is a
crazy thing to think yeah we're the
guinea pigs it's all practice yeah it's
a business and it used to be remember
like I dated a pediatric
anesthesiologist uh on and off for a
very long time so a professional Cosby
literally Cosby should have gotten into
anesthesia never used it on me I'm like
um
um
no I just I fall asleep when men tell
stories
isn't that like a nice dad like at night
time so you would something where where
sounds like a dad telling you night time
a dad dead that's what we were talking
about you're talking about that's
redundant
are there any other kinds no not in this
room dying parents I'm just gonna say
dying parents okay so keep keep
um so real quick let's just try to I'm
gonna try to now you guys I know you
guys think I'm losing my mind I'm not
I'm just having fun with her she's like
my favorite sparring partner on the
planet
um I'm just gonna write down a couple
things that I want to bring up yeah and
do you want to talk about the things
that angered you the our fresh the
biggest curve balls in dealing with your
parent having whatever
um what happened to her you smothered
her with a pillow yeah she's actually in
that pillow
we've turned her into stuffing it's a
it's a ecological way to do something no
one ever tells you when you cremate
someone you get scoops of everyone else
well that's up it's like you have a
little bit of Aunt Edna Tony Jerry no no
no no someone's cat jar no no it's
whoever else was cremated that day I'm
not convinced they're not related
they're in there going and no no I know
but it's everyone else's people yeah
that's what I'm saying you're a family
no no but it's other people's family in
the crap in the Scoops yeah but you just
said my aunt and uncle no no it's
they don't clean in between but fire
cleans things so like where are we I
don't know about that I don't know about
that
okay me either
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
and I'm not saying that sarcastically
I'm just really trying to say that
because I always forget it
but maybe if I spent more time going to
a therapist that I was a good match with
my memory wouldn't be so shoddy because
my brain wouldn't be clogged with a
bunch of stuff that I need to like
excrete isn't the word but I think for
me after having two parents die like I
needed therapy for a different reason
while they were alive right mostly to be
able to go
I'm in therapy because of you I needed
it to guilt my parents
you know
because that's what healthy people do
they go my therapist said that you
shouldn't have done that when I was four
that's not what good therapists do
it has taken me a while to go to enough
and I in therapy it just sounds so
elitist which is why I love better
health because it's actually like
affordable you don't have to leave your
job for two and a half hours it's it's
it's it's it's all online you can do it
from your home okay you're not gonna get
on seven buses to go try to find some
building you know that there that you're
paying four dollars an hour because
they're overhead for the rent for the
the location they decided they want to
be in like on Rodeo Drive and you're
like so why am I no so now you're you're
uh going to the therapist is actually
causing more problems for me at this
point I'm by the time I get to the
therapist it's just to cope with the
stress of having driven here
and then you go into the therapist
you're like hey and they're like I think
you have anger management problems I'm
like I think you have bad judgment on
where your office is
who paid for the Zen Garden out front
who paid for all the Yoga monthlies
sitting on the coffee table who paid for
the little sand thing with the rake
my pain is that going on my bill
I see a lot of diplomas around here
Harvard didn't Epstein work there
I don't know if I like this
or avoid it all
with better help you just have to fill
out a brief questionnaire Don't Panic
it's a good thing right it's they're
going to start showing you the
therapists that are the best match
because therapists all have different
Specialties right so sometimes you can
go to a child trauma therapist you can
go to a therapist that specialized I'm
seriously specializes in grief which I
don't need to go to because I've never
had it
um or sexual stuff or relationship stuff
you know you they all specialize in
different things it's like you can't
just go to any doctor for your migraines
you don't go to a podiatrist for your
migraines
or maybe you should because some they do
say it starts in the feet
do they say that mm-hmm
just fill out a brief questionnaire and
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge that's how it always
should be but most people don't do it
only better help is makes any sense and
is fair to people that need therapy and
thank you if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
uh this isn't written there but if
you're processing grief if you're going
through a breakup or not going through a
breakup my whole thing with therapy now
is about getting ahead of it like you
only go to physical therapy after you've
hurt yourself let's just it to me it's
like stretching and like warm it like
just get ahead of it so you don't
because I think most people think of
therapy is like okay my marriage is
falling apart of that we're going to go
to therapy but it's like get ahead of it
so you don't get to that point where
you're scrambling you know so that's my
new work you know the goal for me is to
be in uh talking to my therapist and
being like I don't have a lot to say
because we've kind of gotten ahead of it
all
um I had a therapist there to be the one
I've been with forever
and we had gotten we had handled so many
problems both real and imagined
that we got to her going okay it might
be time to process the trauma of your
birth
and I was like you know what
next session
because she's like when people are born
it can be very traumatic right if like
you because you go from being in the
womb to going out and it's air
conditioning it's cold and people are
yelling and do your mom have
preeclampsia did your mom were you
sideways was the like that's right
that's the baby's first introduction in
the world so when moms are like I had
preeclampsia and eyes I almost died
you're like that sucks I'm sorry but
your kid went through it too you know
and has a bad association with your
vagina
and all vaginas because frankly they're
a little it was a little touch and go in
there
visit betterhelp.com Whitney today get
10 off your first month that's better
help help.com Whitney
[Music]
okay so you were the one thing you
mentioned before is about the finances
that's the one thing to really consider
and that's an individual responsibility
of oh that looks cute I think that looks
cool why don't people ever do this that
does look good so let me especially on
your lower right here
it looks like you're starting a new
mouth on your chin
because I
I'm still meeting your team
so I need to go there's so much meat in
your teeth
is it bad this is disaster I mean No
One's Gonna See It
bitch the meat in your teeth are like
the light from the Luxor Hotel we all
see it the logs are
so okay let's just back up a tiny bit
because yes it's very expensive when
your parents get sick but hey parents
it's your job to have savings
because you made the decisions that you
made in your 20s and 30s I agree okay
and if you're planning on having
children at any point
whether you're abusing them or not
Starts Now
yeah well that's it is kind of abusive
to be selfish about how you're living
your life if you have children not
considering what the foreseeable future
will look like because we kind of know
now and this is the confusion that I
think people get into moms and dads go
well I'm giving everything to my
children that's that's the stupid way to
do it fine we don't have cancer yet you
please stop smoking get if you really
love me
because I didn't get to have my 20s or
30s
because I was caretaking my parents so I
didn't and I was born an adult so I
never got to have a childhood so when
you guys see me now acting like silly
I'm just like I'm like like I'm like
having fun I fun for the first time ever
because when your mom is in a bed with
her brain all there from a stroke at 62.
top of her game like running public
relations for Neiman Marcus and
Bloomingdale's like my hero and then
gets fucking crippled stroke wouldn't go
to the doctor and I had a doctor
appointment for her two days later and I
had a car to pick her up but she she
wouldn't fucking go to the doctor why
not she wouldn't get a mammogram why not
she's stubborn I don't want to know
because if I know
then I have to do something but it
wasn't breast cancer than the stroke
happens you know what I mean so it's
like the thing you're afraid you might
have
that should just get you to the doctor
and then they'll go uh you have this
other thing yeah I call it the Paul
Revere reveal it happened with my mom
where whatever brings you to the doctors
just the message love it um let's stay
focused because I think a lot stay
focused a lot of people are going to
benefit from this so if your parent if
you are I don't care if you're 15 years
old right now 25 years old you're an
adult enough to be able to sit down with
your parents and go hey guys I know you
want a ground man I want to give me an
allowance and you don't like them on my
phone all the time and you have a lot of
notes for me but what's your plan
that's a great way to do it I think
people don't people don't consider like
you said before you were talking about
living well thinking ahead people don't
think ahead yeah they're thinking right
now to try to get a kid off their phone
honey
sir ma'am power of attorney you
stressing out like they will you
stressing out about your kid being on
your phone is uh thinning the lining of
your heart because you're producing
cortisol and thinning the blood vessels
putting pressure on the blood vessels in
your head so you're giving yourself a
stroke by worrying about your kid and
being a good parent living will medical
directive right can you explain what
that is medical directive is an
appointed person isn't it a medical
directive is the power of attorney
whoever is if the person's incapacitated
they have a pow or POA POA which is
power of attorney yep that person is
selected by the uh when the person's not
on drugs or the lazier relatives who
don't want to deal with it
but they can't do the power of attorney
uh without the person the that's sick
choosing and they have to be sober at
the time they can't if they had a stroke
you wait till they can and you have to
have someone like a witness present
that's like works at the hospital they
have these now it's like a social worker
that will come in those conversations
have to be had in social worker because
then you have three family members going
mom don't you want me to be the power of
attorney like I can just do it it's a
nightmare and then you know what I mean
so some a witness has to be there to
tell you what kind of questions to ask
so she will set the the woman will say
here
um
I can't believe you're sitting on my mom
I almost said Patty which is my mom
um uh there's no one named Lindsay in
their 60s
um there's about to be a whole bunch a
bunch like um you know Haley whatever
who just had a stroke at 65 and has
three kids right they're 24 28 and 38
wants a half who cares
I'm gonna go in and we need to decide
who's gonna be the power of attorney and
the power of attorney decides whether
you treat whether you do dialysis
whether you do an MRI because if you say
yes to the MRI that's that bill's coming
to the power of attorney it's coming to
me right and I'm being asked by
very busy doctors
about very complicated brain procedures
should we do this procedure where we
clean the uh um whatever they're
basically called brain stem out to get
the plaque out
I don't fucking know yeah it is
28. you have to make these huge and I
started studying it
and that's why I made a movie called the
female brain I started learning about
the brand I had to I grew up with
migraines both my parents had Strokes
then they would go hey so the frontal
lobe and the amygdala's Damage should we
do this I'm like don't what you tell me
have you ever had your brain scanned yes
did you go to doctors are so afraid of
being sued now that they won't give you
a suggestion so the only thing I was
able to survive on in my 20s was to say
the doctor what would you do if it was
your dad
but you have to turn around on them like
that but they won't do it anymore
because they're too afraid of being sued
there's so much medical malpractice and
then I have to be like hey man and
there's so much fake medical there's so
much so many people that Sue doctors yep
two things they're about truth there's
good cops and bad cops they're both
um and then
now they won't tell you but
sometimes if you establish a good
relationship with them and are
respectful and if you don't here's the
other thing I have lived in icus and
hospitals when I'm not on tour for 12
years we've been in hospitals here's the
mistake I see a lot of the siblings
making so anyway sorry the power of
attorney you have to ask questions that
aren't leading questions or manipulative
right because you're walking to some
family Dynamic and the mom is like I
guess I need to say yes for Jessie May
to be my power of attorney because
she's not married and the other sister
would remember to rich guy like the the
family members doing all the math of how
to make sure their siblings are taken
care of when they die if they're good if
they can do that and they're picking
power of attorney based on the person
they can think is the most responsible
but sometimes the person's most
responsible is actually the most
controlling and manipulative
so it's like tricky it is very tricky
it's very complicated
yeah and the person who's like the most
established and stable and older that
that was our situation you know we're
I'm one of four girls it was the oldest
sister but it's still it it's not
without complications really cool to
give one you know that was the right
decision that Nancy made but I also
think it's cool to give the fuck up
a responsibility yeah that's the other
thing it's like when you come home and
you're the youngest one or you're the
youngest always a black sheep the
youngest means most mature right
youngest doesn't mean youngest because
the youngest had to fit in an already
established system and basically raise
themselves yeah so the youngest was is
the most precocious old soul the oldest
is usually like can fucking fight but
like they were the most coddled when
they were born right because they were
the first child by the time they got to
four your parents were like she's fine
yeah they just let me go I was out in
the woods we normally get setting things
on fire we normally get parent uh
parented by our older sibling if you
have that big of a family
it is um
the power of attorney is tricky though I
feel like it's it's something that
usually people are just
kind of you can also turn siblings
against each other it turns siblings
against each other but I also feel like
people scramble to get it because you
never know when something's gonna go you
can happen so you can have it in your
living will
which should be done
if you decide you're going to get
married and you decide you want children
you should just get your living will
done yes just get it done you should if
you have children and you don't have a
living will they should be taken from
you I don't know that's extreme
obviously but you're talk this is
someone who went through the the hell of
it it's just that you need to choose dad
and mom who you want the power of
attorney to be kind of now because of
course your judgment is going to be
let's so this is let's get ahead of it
yep so that we're not all just fine
unscrambling because no one gets out
alive or it's a common for all of us
right and it just is a little bit easier
it's and it makes it makes it so that
you don't go you're it's not guaranteed
that you go bankrupt
because at the end when you're
scrambling to get the finances in order
and especially if you are someone whose
family succumbs to a disease that's like
a neurodegenerative disease where a
person can't talk and they can't
communicate but then you do butterfly
effect and you do
you want me to be the power of attorney
mom squeeze my hand if yes
you then you get into that so my dad and
mom both really couldn't so it turned
into that right
um did you have to do if you want this
person to be your caretaker squeeze
twice no squeeze that's a no do I mean
you'd have to just like but you have to
be in there
and balancing your job which is earning
you the money to pay for all this shit
and you're like like I mean for me I
felt like
I felt like um and this is such an
elitist conversation because to even be
able to go to hospitals or nursing homes
is already elitist do you know what I
mean to be able to walk out and it not
crumble your fucking life yeah yeah but
like a place that you're you're leaving
your parent in a uh at a dog pound you
know what I mean you're leaving them at
like a Doggy Daycare Center and they're
just like in a cage and like I don't
know if their teeth isn't getting
cleaned I don't know if they're getting
by the way probably not because the way
this culture treats the elderly is
Criminal the way we just disregard old
people and sick people is Criminal this
is in the direction we're going as a
species I don't think like we're all in
a Summit here and uh like I just
personally find it pretty um inhumane
the way that
um
in some Asian cultures
dogs are treated and the person said
back well we find it pretty despicable
the way Americans treat old people
they're not wrong they're not fucking
wrong wrong they were like you guys just
put them in cages to die yeah it's this
it's in it's worse I and I I'm an animal
lover I get it I have three dogs I love
animals but the way we treat our people
not only that okay yes so my mom
um she died technically of complications
of stroke I actually say that since uh
uh my my grandfather died
um from like a vanity surgery because he
was dating a younger woman that wanted
to like go to a
um he served in the military like a
military party and he wanted to dance
never mind that she had already like
married seven other men uh that were old
and when he had a heart attack she stole
his keys like but but we know what was
the surge I need to know what it was
vanity it was a knee surgery and um uh
he walked four miles every day at I
think 84 comes from coal mining worked
in Coal Mines had a cool company
so like should have been dead like
breathed was in better shape than any of
us never out of breath inhaling cult
like we're wired for like my I'm wired
for that I'm wired
Coal Miner's Daughter yes
believe me no I believe you um it's just
a it's a it's a new factoid about you
and so then um he went and he got a
surgery that he didn't need so he's
still in perfectly good health he goes
under the voluntary surgery
um epidural they paralyze him so every
time you're going under surgery
I mean Kanye's didn't Connie's mom die
anesthesia Usher's wife went into
cardiac arrest under anesthesia Joan
Rivers
in anesthesia and needles in your back
to numb you
is fucking dangerous
um again it's called a practice real
quick side side note you know me my
tangents I'll tell you where I recently
heard this on a podcast it might have
been blocked and reported like maybe
maybe maybe
um but when you
go to medical school now and graduate
your degree is obsolete in 14 months
because of how much has changed wow is
that an incentive to re-educate
what it could be so it's like by the
time it should be there's two I feel
like there's too many stagnant medical
professionals but every year there's
like a um
what's it called every year there's like
a refresh or two you're supposed to go
to Hawaii and do a conference and here's
the latest so remember when you guys
remember when we thought
um drinking vodka was good for pregnant
women
right
we're having a re-education don't tell
the ones that they would just do that
remember the leech thing
yeah probably not leeches anymore I feel
like agents have more seminars like that
for the company than actual doctors do I
feel like the entertainment agents you
know they go away on those like I love
they called an agency but no one that's
rep there has any no
but they go away on those like the way
they call it an agent like you're like a
secret agent my new favorite my
obsession is landlords
are you alone and they come and they
have a beer belly are you a lord of this
studio apartment that's owned by
Scientology on Hauser some fact I had a
toupee who smells like tuna opens the
door Hello Lord of them
the lord of the land is here
sir you're not wearing any underwear and
I know that because there also aren't
pants on
landlord's supposed to have pants
no he's an agent CA
who gets more education that's someone
the doctor that is someone who is just
coming to chat with you our CAA agents
have more education about the
entertainment industry they have more
frequent refreshes of what's going on in
the industry than doctors do about
health no they've never known but they
still have more than doctors know
they're too busy buying rent leasing
Audis doctors they don't even get
nutrition
Nutritional Health they don't even get
like education on nutrition
but if they wanted to they don't want to
can I ask you a question um I do want to
talk about that because do you think
that we're just so in love as friends
that we just get so excited to go on
tangents or do you think we're trying to
navigate grief that might come up I'm
open to it okay I love I love talking
about it only because I just really I
don't want to cry because I just
finished my makeup you can you can
create yeah I know I can I just like
don't I like I I feel like I've here's
I'm just gonna say a couple things that
I observed so any I never want to be
pity that's my biggest thing and I think
part of the reason I was such a solo
operator Lone Wolf for the longest time
in comedy is because I didn't want
anyone to know about my family situation
because it's like it's not really
embarrassing uh it's like no one wants
to hear about that it's just too much of
a bummer like and then if you do tell
the truth it's like are you okay and
then you have someone that's like
someone pities you but do you feel that
way or do you think that that's your
fear that you're going to be someone's
burden because maybe you felt like
you've had to deal with so much you felt
a burden for yourself I just actually
lied
I don't want to talk about it because
all I do is think about it yeah but
don't you think sometimes in releasing
it you literally release it when you
release it out of your mouth you can
release it out of your being at least
for me that's what it was yeah grief had
such a grip on me for so long and I
didn't I didn't realize it
this is you don't realize it you because
you don't there's no time to realize it
and there's nothing to compare it to
because it's there's no blueprint
everyone has a different like different
grief right and even the the Kubler-Ross
model in the other uh the older model
with seven stages Kubler-Ross is five
it's not that's at a time before like
therapeutic Academy like a lot of the
love language stages of grief like um by
the way gifts you by on wedding
anniversary not true is still on that
list like a lot by the way you know what
else the first aid kit needs to be
updated yeah we need a rape whistle it
doesn't have tampons in it it doesn't
have you know I mean yeah it should be a
little mini bottle of wine I'm gonna
deal with if you're dying you can at
least have a shot
I just in the last like
two weeks
in here
saboteur
are you an ASMR Aficionado like that how
many people just unsubscribe for just
because of that rude rude 2000 rude so
um uh I just realized for the first time
uh in two weeks at least that I'm
conscious of I don't dress
for men that I don't even want to date
to want to fuck me it's so great it's so
liberating
and the funny thing you say because we
were talking about it's weird like is
that a grief thing well I was gonna say
we're talking about country safety
looking for safety but I also just got
off birth control well after 25 years
that's gonna you're adjusting you know
there's women who you have to be careful
about who you pick during the month and
where you are in your cycle who you
choose to marry because yeah you might
not find them attractive it's so
talented that month so the quick answer
for that I did I'm not trying to promote
this no one can find my HBO special so
it's not like I'm trying to drive
traffic to it
um I did talk about that because it
changes our olfactory glands and the way
we smell yeah so if you are madly in
love with someone and want to marry him
or cool just go off birth control for a
year and then make sure it's still right
yeah wait let it all adjust and see and
don't get pregnant during that time
yeah
in the interim he can come on your face
romance we need to like be more I you
know I have an apology to make I feel
like I went too hard at guys
fucking your tits
get your dick off my heart I did this
whole bit that was like get your dick
off my wire trying to fuck my heart like
get it away like you know what I mean
and coming on the face I used to make
fun of
eyes down is fine or just let me get
some like a like a monocle like let's
let me put some glasses on first like I
think we need sex
goggles yeah comb goggles come on my on
my face my tits
just don't fucking lock me down with
this baby I'm here for that but then
again paint me like Bob Ross paint me
like one of your French Bob Ross girls
I'm ready you got your Texas hanger
Texas Hingham Texas Hold'em hang them
um
how about let's take down the photos of
her and cornrows maybe we're helping her
by not blasting this those are actually
not technically cornrows oh
oh but but can I see I like the idea
that they I'm thinking more like turn of
the century have you noticed those like
that guys that are these ones
uh Amelia Earhart the the Spanish Flu
mask that that'd be more with the
elephant
um with the elephant the Spanish Flu
masks can I ask you a question have you
noticed a linear relationship between
men who really want to make eye contact
during sex and them being Psychopaths
yeah that's too much Focus someone who's
like look at me look at me look at me
when you come look at me
it's like I need a blink buddy like I
I'm by the way I'm on my bat oh how and
I can't if I look at you on my belly if
I look at you I won't swivel like I'm
gonna throw out my neck trying to get
you come on that would be fun dude
that's crows let's go crows before homes
I even put the little hat on too so um
uh it's not that it's not gonna be a
little on your head why is it why do I
feel like Prince is under there
remember prance
so so wait wait wait let me wrap up one
but let me just let me just really we'll
never wrap it just so you know
two people who have lost the people they
love the most
are having the most fun yeah it's not a
coincidence no it's it's liberating it's
you'll be okay so and they die I was
telling him and I say they because I
don't know if your parents identify as
male or female oh they were my dad was
hetero my mom was complete he was a
hetero male and my mom was a total
feminine female I was just kidding I
just I wasn't okay
um I was telling him you're talking
about outfits so the one thing that
someone said I never really read
comments but when I was everyone that
reads comments says that I don't um I
went through all of the ones from our
last video just to see what people had
said oh I would like oh that's good I
feel like people liked our last video
it's not great stuff we won't get into
it I don't know but the people people
that write great stuff don't write it
yeah no it was great it was awesome yeah
it was great but the people that were
mean love us
like if you if you go out of your way to
write a negative comment about me that
is linked to your
email
like you're obsessed with me because it
will always be on your digital footprint
that you called me a busted cunt
and you will in 20 years let's say
you're 18. 20 years when you're fighting
for custody of your children
and I'm your wife's lawyer
we'll go can we just pull up his uh
comment history where he commented and
called women cunts
I think she's got full custody I think
we can all just go home people aren't
thinking ahead every comment you're
making is you're losing a future custody
battle and you're losing future
employment so if I was the kind of
person that actually wanted a production
company to run a business which I don't
the first thing I would do with my
background check guys I would go can you
go through all the comments they've made
on other people's accounts especially
famous people you should create a whole
industry for that I'm sure there's
probably some that are doing it but
that's that's a sweet side job I just
don't have that I just don't I don't
yeah so are things as common as Comics
we say the problem and it's someone
else's job to solve it we can't we're
dumb yeah we make the observation we
have the good ideas deal with it and if
it's a bad idea make it better or just
ignore it but so I do want to do
Instagram
for Comics Instagram for Comics same
thing but if you're a comic no other
Comics can see what you're posting
because we don't post enough and promote
ourselves enough because we're
embarrassed
yeah that other Comics I every time I
post right I'm like hey guys I'm gonna
be in Orlando and I'm like Chris Rock's
okay this rocks might see this and I
just can't
we're not selling out Orlando and I'd
rather not sell out in Orlando than have
Chris Rock go
foreign
[Laughter]
okay pass on something that helped you
and I would say when you're going
through grief as soon as my dad
um died and I'm crying because I'm so
grateful because I think I've um I've
always beat myself up a little about
being like I hang out with the wrong
people like my friends are narcissists
like I gravitate towards unhealthy
narcissists that are like
make me a doormat and like that kind of
thing which was just an old story and
and mostly my doing that I you know
um
um um Okay so
when you're done when I was when my dad
died I got a call from I can say who
they were Lizzie Kaplan Uh Kevin
Christie the great uh painter and
painted that Behind These those two
things behind you Kevin Christie
um and uh by the way the horse one he
like sketched in 20 minutes like when
he's amazing so funny he's fine artist
now but open for me on the road forever
worked on the only fans just everything
and he's also working on the merch
business with me now so the merch is
about to get good guys
um and um
Casey Wilson
um and they all call me separately and
we're like hey
gentle suggestion don't talk to anyone
who hasn't lost a parent yes and it's
not their fault they just won't know
what to say and and just relieve them of
bothering you just just avoid don't go
to parties for a while because what
you're not going to realize is how much
at parties people complain about my mom
won't stop texting oh my God
my dad is a fucking he can't even
fucking use Facebook and then you're
like oh really sounds tough like oh my
mom's calling you guys oh can I take it
yeah it is a nightmare I'd love to you
know and then like my mom went jogging
this morning she's 70. it's so annoying
it's like my mom jogged into a grave by
noon
I thought you pushed her in I did
but she was running away from me
laughs
oh my God
can we put my mom on the other side
the Nancy and Patty pillow
merch is about to get good by the way
by the way her name arch nemesis was
Nancy the second wife the wife that came
after her ooh that like showered with me
but anyway
um I wow these non-sequarters are
jarring
that reminds me we have to start
pickling
what are thoughts because I agree that's
what doing a podcast is we're preserving
I wholeheartedly agree wait there was
the famine's coming yeah so Russia has
half of our fertilizer right which means
the famine's coming in two years okay
let's start pickling oh I was like is
this a new topic we're starting or I
mean it's all the same topic this is
just by the way this is what a
conversation is this is what we want to
like what's a podcast
but wait
foreign
by the water in West Virginia until I
was about 14 I just realized that
there's a lot of stuff you don't realize
till you your parents are dead because
if you brought them up with them they
would take it as an attack or criticism
or you just subconsciously like can't
process it I kind of know it but can't
process it so I went uh uh my some of my
closest friends on New Year's Eve tried
to Stage an intervention on me to go to
a psych it was psychiatric ward because
I like finally for the first time like
had a New Year's Eve off I've always
done stand up you did it this year yeah
it was my last year we'll do it next
year we might do it next year if it's
um if it's if it serves it fits
Bare Minerals company party yes
we will do that because I need to sniff
around this or I need to do you want to
see like what what they're doing down on
the Bare Minerals no I already know
Factory it's bad stuff is the bare
mineral Cobalt shark fins is this made
out of cobalt it's shark fin is it red
shark fin that actually might be so um
are they so their blood's not cribs got
it
um
so I think when my parents died like all
I think I'm I'm trepidatious to say this
because I don't want to say you're not
an adult until your parents have died
that's not fair because we were adults
the second we were born and some of us
had to adult our parents I think it's a
true statement like but words the people
that
some people will hear oh you're calling
me a mature I'm not an adult just as my
parents haven't died yes it's true and
it's not a bad way no it's not bad at
all but it's you're not an adult until
you become become untethered from the
people who made you interesting you're
not an adult until you have lost the
supportive if you were lucky enough to
have that that supportive Foundation
you're not an adult until but it might
not have been supportive either which is
right but even still it's on white
because adversity makes you stronger
even still I think when that is severed
whether the relationship was strong or
not at the point of death you you don't
realize that level of mortality and
loneliness that is associated with the
loss of your parents I felt lonelier
when they were alive and that's for me
personally because because I think this
is such an interesting conversation
because
yo you had a very close relationship
with your parents you had a
um one way so the parental relationship
with the child is a one-way giving
receiving relationship it does not go
the other way the child does not give to
the parent ever that's the problem with
our culture in our culture no emotional
support so a lot of our moms not no
fault of their own
they look to us for their emotional
support and we were just kids the toxic
ones right bye not their fault by using
the family system of guilt because what
we're doing here is breaking ancestral
Cycles yes we're breaking them so if we
didn't do this I would just do the same
thing to my kid that was done to me of
course and it wasn't her fault so she
was controlled by guilt that was only
the only way my single my mom's single
mom was able to get them to work on the
farm because there's no man's cantaloupe
farm and they just had to like why do
you think Santa Claus was invented it
was the only way to control children
they're watching you
if you're good you're going to get a
present like like that some parent was
like you guys we like what um how do we
get them to stop we need something we
need something we need someone to come
down the chimney with gifts and it works
like you know it's so it's like
surveillance kind of worse so um so for
me because I think I felt like I was the
parent right away I was also a quote
surprise I was conceived two months
after my sister so I was
I wasn't a burden I know I'm not I I I
knew that my life's purpose was to not
be a burden is to be a kid that they
wanted to have you know and not one that
they're like oh fucking this guy oops I
didn't want to be the oops that like
ruined everyone's plan so I was like no
problem I got it I'll Raise Myself and I
will make myself so fucking useful that
when you guys have strokes in 20 years I
got it you know what I mean I'll save
the day don't like don't
um forget about me but then I my sister
and I were separated we were thick as
thieves basically I I mean Irish twins
and then separated when we were 11 and
12 and lived in separate places yeah so
you had a totally different it sounds
like your experience and I don't think I
ever forgave my parents for that but I
think they thought they were doing the
right thing at the right time I'm sure
most people do separating siblings is
just like kind of a No-No well that's
like you know unless your source of
learning yeah unless they're a danger
and your your your source of
corroborating reality yeah did that just
happen wait right I think she was drunk
and connecting and feeling like you have
a a home in this world that you're not
burdening or just like a friend
you know what I mean you're it's like
your best friend is your sister even if
you're fighting or your brother even if
you're fighting that's you guys make you
start each other stronger you thought
you'd make each other funny you know so
a kid that grew up with a sister and
then all of a sudden was alone so that's
why when I lived in Roanoke Virginia I
mostly lived with the animals or my
friends so I learned body
um I learned how to talk to horses like
how to communicate with horses not talk
to them I'm not that crazy but like
communicate with them and dogs and stuff
because girls need protection
we need dogs we need something to love
too and we need something that'll
protect us yes you know like a Beowulf
you know this the person with the
witchery and sorcery book
really didn't like the Beowulf comment I
find inconsistent I don't not like it I
just
have never read it and I'm not sorry
really but Angelina Jolie did the movie
version with that suffice
I guess
hey y'all save time and have the energy
you need to tackle everything on your
to-do list with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
factors fresh never frozen meals are
ready in just two minutes so all you
have to do is just heat and enjoy no
matter what your lifestyle Factor has
the meals to help you live it to the
fullest with keto calorie smart vegan
plus veggie and Protein Plus meals on
the venue each week prepared by chefs
and approved by dietitians each meal has
the all the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long with 34 Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's always something new to
try plus you can round out your meal and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of 36 plus quick bites juices
smoothies and more satisfying add-ons
achieve and maintain your goals this
year with Factor get America's number
one whoa
number one
so here's the thing in advertising you
can't say that if it's not true you know
I mean you have rappers who are like I'm
number one and then another rapper's
like I'm number one and you're like well
you can't both be number one which this
is the number one America's number one
ready to eat meal kit and start saving
time eating well and living your best
year ever head to factormeals.com
Whitney 60 to use code Whitney 660 to
get 60 off your first box that's code
Whitney 60 at factormeals.com Whitney
60 to get sixty percent off your first
box sorry about my voice I lost my voice
because I was on a soapbox when I should
have been eating my Factor box
so I share a lot
to make Strangers Like Me this is what's
weird yeah I agree okay totally agree do
the intervention on me right now this is
why this is this is mental illness right
what we do no I think we're um the
elders that are passing on
because school doesn't teach anyone
anything so we have to teach we have to
share our experience yep because we have
to make the podcast we wish existed when
we were 25. right tell us things the
only reason I fucking wrote a book
avoiding mistakes yeah I'm not avoiding
mistakes but the only way we can the
only way
it's more tolerable to live with
the Injustice and fuckery that we went
through is to kind of know that less
people are going to go through it right
or another tools they have some tools
and they're not they're and they'll
maybe be some if someone with OCD
and a big heart and like a purpose a
need for a purpose listens to this
they're like my fucking purpose is gonna
be to make the law where anyone who has
children legally has to have a will
because it's illegal
to not have your kid in school
but it's legal to not have a will when
your kid's 40. and also the fact that we
aren't taught these sort of financial
things in school it should be illegal
the things that actually we need to
implement I took a class when I lived in
Virginia called some schools do it not I
had homemak they just taught us how to
make cupcakes in shitty birdhouses
the shittier the better
they like shitty ones they do kind of
like shitty you know what I mean like
moss dried moss on it kind of have you I
this is such a dumb question I can't
believe I love that that most people in
L.A have bird houses but not houses for
themselves
just build a house teach me how to build
like a house for not Birds yeah not not
a teeny house out of popsicles because
any bird that can fit in this house
isn't going to protect my property do
birdwatch
do you have a bird they watch me
I bet you they do I bet you birds in
your backyard definitely dude we're
taking back the fucking Forest what
aren't you teaching crows to bring you
tools you're teaching crows to bring you
tools you say it as if I'm like
came up with the I'm jealous what kind
of tools like power tools so if you
leave out peanuts uh maybe a little bit
of meat like a piece of Just Turkey or
something so they they meat gets their
attention right because they're
scavengers but they ultimately want to
eat like peanuts that have the casing on
it sorry
they like to yeah break it apart okay my
grandfather after in being a coma and uh
working for uh Cole uh had a candy store
good Mr Peanut all right quit bragging
Jesus outside there was a huge Mr Peanut
out front I know me and my fucking way
to Lay It All Out West Virginia
ancestors and they're uh they're
what is it when wealth goes generational
wealth fuck so close I didn't know that
word
um uh you ever listen to Appalachian
people Frank dangerous that's what I
come from I know this is how that's what
I sound like beautiful so so I started
so when I I'm curious what happened to
you but you have sisters that like I was
separated from my sister as soon as my
mom died we realized we had been like
not of No blamelessly I say this
blamelessly we had parents that lied to
themselves not us I think there's a
difference between right now
um I'm gonna lie to you by saying Hey
Jessie may I really have to go I have
something in an hour so let's wrap this
up that's just a lie right right but if
I go um
Jesse I think we need to
um cut this now because I just don't
think people are gonna look like this
and whatever that's me lying to myself
right so it's like I think that my
parents went no this will be good for
her oh no I'll fix that later you know
what I'll handle that another time you
know I'm just gonna make more money laid
you know what I mean they they are
they're Liz Holmes they are like I think
she believed she just needed more time
yeah to make it all work but if you
think like that you're gonna run out of
time right so it's like
so
um
I think that I've never had time to I
didn't even know my mom's dad's name
you didn't know your grandfather's name
no but
my dogs for eight years been named Frank
and his name's Frank that's fucking
weird it's not it's but kind of makes
it's like so all the info so I collect
vintage books and weird tchotchkes and
then as soon as my mom died and I had a
sec we did 11 days of Home hospice
which I want to talk about because they
don't tell you how that works and how
they die and by the way the doctor does
not tell the patient their terminal
they deliver the patient to the home
where the hospice is going to be and the
patient is like what are we doing here
leaving the burden for you
it's such a fucked process and when they
get there they're not on the meds they
were on before it's it my mom's like a
stone cold sober
feeding to about three days
she came heavy she came in me and my
sister were like getting all ready we
get this we're in front of the ocean
we're putting on like Enya like her
favorite songs we're putting uh photos
of like all her friends up we're like
lining up FaceTime calls with her
friends she's officially in home hospice
she shows up she's been on morphine for
a month in the hospital you know so
we're like oh she's a vegetable or
whatever
she comes in she's like where are we
what are we doing why are we here we're
like
literally
and we go into the room next door
never organize clear
when I was like a kid
they've never seen her this clear
because she's been on for 12 years
antidepressants and the painkillers and
stuff to keep her sedated so that she's
not having to process her reality so she
comes and she said why are we here what
are we doing what a horrible time to
process your reality at the end then I
go into the fucking my sister and her
like who else was there
like it literally was like gosh the
feeding tubes I went out for three days
you can get it back in let's just give
her so she couldn't swallow so both my
parents their Strokes eventually
affected their ability to swallow which
is how you aspirate
your food basically um
you choke stays yeah you choke or
aspirate uh Long's pneumonia okay also
nursing homes if they're not making sure
that the people there are hydrating
properly they're gonna get UTIs
septic and it happens a lot more than
people my mom would get and when she
would get UTIs it makes you like manic
yeah it does it makes you like you're
like right on the wall like help water
you know what I mean it was like but she
didn't have she only one hand and
couldn't you know what I mean it was
just like and then her teeth were not
being cared for so she got infections in
her mouth and septic
so it's like you've got to either remove
all the teeth it's just like who it's
just a whack-a-mole right it is so she
comes in to me my sister are like
she's not dying like they're wrong
they're wrong what a mindful but then
they say it becomes after 12 years it's
about quality of life it's about this is
going to keep happening right now you
just have to decide how she's going to
die do you want her to die in a fucking
Hospital
with beep beep beeps and that's not
there because the visiting hours are
till eight or do we want her to die here
with some dignity and we can all be here
and with her while she crosses over
because it's like
she's been through enough like it's time
for us to
like she wouldn't want us to be she
wouldn't want me to be putting all the
money into these nursing homes and
hospitals she would be wanting me to buy
land for my sister and her name to build
wealth do you know what I mean so it
just gets to be this crazy thing where
like your own parent like
doesn't want you to keep them alive you
know what I mean it's a thing where
you're like but I'm not done with you
like I'm not ready for you to go but
like so I'm just gonna keep doing
casinos and fucking making more money
because like I'm just not ready for you
to go even though I know you want to go
you know and it's like
like what they don't prepare you for is
one day your parent might look at you
and go like
and you're not gonna fucking know what
to do with it
so then I'm like in the hospital and in
the hospital they won't provide cannabis
right and which is just so they won't
give her a sleeping pill it's fine but
she can't swallow so I'm like can we get
she just wants to sleep she just wants
to fucking sleep that's all you know
what I mean and the body can't heal if
you can't sleep and she's like and I'm
like Mom what do you need what do you
need I just want to sleep have you ever
tried to sleep in an ICU baby
it's just like why it's why it's like
it's muscle yeah it's a total insult to
your sensory yeah and we're hyper
sensitive people so it wasn't like she
she couldn't sleep in she can't sleep in
the quiet in her own bed much like we're
total Night Owl insomniacs you know and
so and my mom and I lived in an
apartment and um
when I lived with her and we slept and
we shared a bet you know we lived in an
apartment together like we were more
like best friends you know like and an
apartment where we were like surrounded
on four sides really and the noise noise
like and that's another thing about
apartments
lord of the land you need to start
making
um
people fucking sleep is do not feel
vital people are not
like I'm already worried about a com
apartment complexes and radiation
pounding it because everyone in there
has their own Wi-Fi let's say emfs is
fake I would love for it to be even on
the one percent chance the EMF radiation
is doing something bad like let's just
have
let's just prevent I think copper paint
that has copper in it lead paint
whatever but
like there's like some evidence that
says the emfs and I think most of the
evidence has to do with the fact that
T-Mobile has already put aside like 300
million dollars for future court cases
because there is a law
a telecommunications law that that
um phone companies which all these are
categorized as Wi-Fi Apple tech
companies they do not have to reveal
that there has been any injury from
their products
unless it's a
person that fell off a phone pole
like fixing the wires that's the only
thing they're legally obligated to
disclose
so let's say if all these phones are
giving us cancer and killing our sperm
and stuff and they know that they're not
legally obligated to tell us and that
guy or woman who fell off the fly
probably did because they didn't get
good sleep in there but why are they
saving all this money up do you know
what I mean yeah they're preparing yeah
they know why wouldn't they just start
making EMF proof why don't they start
solving the very problem they're
creating
it's like Philip Morris is getting into
Vapes like smart they don't give a fuck
um or they're just not thinking forward
enough like they can't see far ahead
enough to know that this temporary
solution is going to be a problem or
they just don't care to create a problem
for a solution for the problem that they
are or they're like I'm not going to be
here when this happens I'll be gone I'll
be retired and I'll be living on a yacht
I'll be on Epstein's Island like that I
just bought whatever so
we're in the hospital and like she can't
sleep they won't give sleeping pills
foreign
I'm not going to say all the stuff I did
but I was able to get the weed delivery
service this is so selfish to do this
because a lot of states don't have weed
legal I don't think but you can get the
tincture you know what I mean I did the
same thing with my dad I snuck it in the
hospital and just Mom yep but then I'm
like what if she aspirates on this and I
kill her
well that's I mean that's a real thought
because you're just so stressed and we
just had to survival very slow smooth as
fast also like you put it on so
you can obviously absorb medicine
through the porous your skin obviously
your mouth so it would just I would try
to put it on the side of her cheek so it
would just absorb through her cheek yeah
so I would just like put it on a
numbness orbit down and people are like
I'm just like putting my hand down my
mom's looking like it was like wow they
really do have a interesting
relationship because she wants her to go
weird way to go I just say come over I'm
like
um so I saw this in the Kevorkian
documentary like no one prepares you for
when one of your parents says like I
don't wanna to do this anymore one of
the nurses was saying that towards the
end with my mom she was starting to
reach for her feeding tube and trying to
pull it out she she was she had her wits
about her and she was done she fought
for as long as she could but then it is
that sort of weird mental and then she
would have to see you guys with broken
hearts right which is like for a mom
just fucking kill me dude it's terrible
and
the real frustrating part was like she's
not being able to fucking be there
not being able to fucking be there I
felt so bad because you were touring
just being here like just trying to get
there but the one thing I'll say is like
if you were there
it would probably kill hurt her I just
wanted to be there in the fight she
wouldn't want you to be um
she wouldn't want you to not be living
your life and she wouldn't want to be
the person holding you back from living
you know what I mean so it's this fucked
up thing whereas like we're designed to
all be together at every stage of life
and we're all living a different country
cities countries like families are so
spread out now that like when there is a
death that like it's like I gotta get on
a plane I can afford a fucking 500 plane
ticket to get there tonight and when
it's a situation like your mom which was
a longer prolonged situation she also
went to she wanted to go back to DC and
also no one prepares you for the parent
telling you what they want and you going
I don't like that you also not also no
one can afford it number one number two
no you can't have a dog even though I
want you to be able to have one
like it's not this nursing home doesn't
take it so I have to tell my mom she
can't have a fucking dog like put a fuck
gun in my mouth dude and like like she
just wanted a pug like she just she
loved pugs and so I would like try to
bring him by and stuff but it was just
like
she didn't want to see him because she
just knew she couldn't have it you know
what I mean it's like don't show me
things I can't have you know it was just
like I get her like a computer she
couldn't even use like it was just like
it's just so you're you're trying to
figure it all out and you're trying to
and then rectify the situation I just
feel like I'm disappointing her but like
I do feel like the one good thing
foreign
just clean up this thing
um
so
by the way wipe your tears with my mom
can you my mom uh I learned so I can put
lipstick on without a mirror I bet you
can't do it you got a real pretty mouth
okay
I'm gonna let you have it because we're
crying
is it perfect oh it's cute especially
with the makeup stain on the side pretty
good
that's really beautiful I love that
you're becoming one with my mom pillow
you know what's fucked up
that's racist
did you just show me white out are you
trying to say something
it's racist if it's on black paper it's
not racist
if it's on black paper my you know what
was messed up was I had to say goodbye
to my mom on Face Time
and then they dropped the laptop
and my sister's like here take this and
I'm like I'm not a this I'm a person I
realize I'm a lap I'm I'm on FaceTime
right now but I am a person my sister's
like here take this and then I'm I'm
propped up
foreign
and I'm like hello
hello
oh God it was so fucked up obviously you
made her death about you yeah I'm like
oh hello can I can't I literally go I
can't see
by the way it's probably better that you
couldn't like I needed to see like let
me see her dying I'm not gonna tell you
who this person is now but if you're in
my how many times am I going to do that
um
uh
if you're like in my like wolf pack
right
like um let's say one of your dogs
passes away in five years whatever right
it's I I don't think it's gonna happen
to us
um that our dogs are gonna die I'm just
gonna drop them off at the farm where
they live forever yes they live forever
they're running in this guy it's fine I
the my dog from when I was a teenager
like I'm like he still lives with this
woman Grace she's dead but I think the
farm is still going yeah they're running
around all the dogs yeah and so
um
if uh someone in my wolf pack has an
animal uh dog Diet cat I can't help you
um they have nine more lives why you
know I mean can't they just come back to
life like I don't know they're also
satanic have they ever been one last cat
is better
I mean look
I don't know they suck out your breath
when you sleep at night asks Steven King
all facts all animal facts awesome
Animal Planet Morgan Freeman said it too
also cats handle their own deaths so
when they're ready to die they leave the
house
they put on a little because they were
just robe and they're like
father take me on to my next life
because I have nine more eight more
after that yeah you have nine lives
that's what a weird number why nine
because it's not perfect 10.
one more than eight I mean I feel like
we're La nines
I'll take it don't you think
I feel like we're nines ever we're only
deducting the points for being
self-sufficient I only deduct one point
I'm like I'm gonna make myself a 10 just
for personality I feel like I'm a 10.
but if you're in LA 10 personality works
against you so now I'm back down to a
six
is that the math
I mean look women suck at math wait what
were we saying before we got on the cat
hate one sec not a cat they just they're
fine they when they're ready to die they
leave because they don't want their
owners to see them so I've rescued two
cats before
um in the middle of the street
in off Laurel Canyon because literally
you'll see a pack of coyotes and then
there's like a fucking cat I'm like how
stupid are these fucking animals right
not even coyotes don't want to eat cats
I mean would you no
um because they eat mice with
toxoplasmosis and they let's not forget
to add the fact that cats eat you
quicker than dogs do when you die in the
house oh look this is the brand I prefer
clearly
what is it why do I have an Avon
eyeliner oh wow that goes with my bra
Avon lady dude Mary Kay and Avon like I
have some questions about those
businesses sex Cults answered next
question
yeah
that checks out
um or no sex called like never ever so I
take this fucking cat I get in my car
it's shitting everywhere it's got all
the hair for no reason we're in La why
does a cat need all this hair in the
desert oh my gosh like nine hairballs in
my fucking trying to eat my breath I
take it to the 24-hour fucking thing
what's the fucking thing uh vet okay and
the woman's like um
feels the back feels the chip runs the
chip and goes oh this this cat belongs
to so and so it's been in a couple times
this week and I was like well this woman
doesn't deserve to have a cat then like
what the fuck and then we call the women
and I'm like hi do you want me to bring
your cat back and she goes can you
please not it's just
it's trying to die and no one will let
it oh oh I see this is an analogy about
your mom in L.A no no no not at all okay
no no I'm not that deep in La if you see
a stray dot you just stop everything and
pull over or even if like you the
pedophiles just continue on there's a
there's an animal that needs me yes
there's an 18 year old cat that's about
to die who needs me injured alive for
another 20 minutes injured War veteran
that's dying on the side of the road I
can't be bothered so then I was like
because by the way she's like it cost me
a thousand dollars to come in and get
the cat so every time someone rescues my
cat that's gonna die and an hour it cost
me a thousand dollars so I'm I'm going
broke on this
and frankly I'm kind of sick of waking
up and getting mouth to mouth from a
devil
living will uh I would like to die
um if you want to be cremated where do
you want the Ashes to go do you want
them to be divided between the children
do you want them to uh be scattered
because also something they don't tell
you is that so if my mom was 120 pounds
how much do you think the ashes weighed
Haley
um
I have no idea five pounds 18 pounds wow
so that lady was all boned the urns you
see I know she by the way was on hospice
11 days no feeding tube
11 days
and also specify how many scoops you
want two scoops of Timmy one scoop to
but also
she died doing what she loved I think
then so uh but also by the way let me
stop you right there let's say we're
doing cremation okay first you find a
cremation company you talk to a couple
you ask a couple questions
where is The Cremation facility when you
pick the body up how long in between
getting the body
do you wait to cremate and why because
you're getting charged by the day for
that storage of that body
and then when the cremation does happen
do not let them send the Ashes to
an apartment complex
an office building
a coffee company
imagine
someone accidentally a Hollywood prop
house
where do you have them sent it's a trick
question
you don't you don't you go pick them up
correct yeah you don't you know this
isn't something and then bring the Urn
to them
and they put it in the each one
otherwise you're at home fucking used in
your pooper scooper it's very weird and
you sneeze and then it's raining off or
snowing mom Merry Christmas or also by
the way like you use the scooper and
then like do what put in the dishwasher
yeah you're gonna go get your protein
powder after that like what am I
so then
um uh sorry I'm jumping around cremation
so yes it is uh the adult's
responsibility to already have that in
writing and if there is a funeral and
they want to be buried in the ground
which um I think we should cancel that
soon and I'll tell you why
um
taking out another page
we also talked about
um
I want to cancel cemeteries but but but
but if uh it's a funeral
first of all you should have maybe
figured out a way to put money aside for
it my dad's funeral will cost a little
more than fifteen thousand there were
other expenses who's gonna pay for the
funeral help us decide it gets messy
financially
I didn't realize I was paying for it I'm
happy to it's like you're at a club
you're like who ordered all this vodka
we're at the VIP table what the hell
where'd this bill come from and then
everyone's like okay everyone got their
morning everyone's like and you're
you're stuck with the bill of death
which by the way I'm fine if I just have
a heads up I can put money as if I know
at 25 it will be me and my Aunt Betty
and my sister's responsibility we can
behave accordingly I won't buy those
Aldo knee-high boots
you might have you might want to be out
there being a little champ on the
weekends I'll shoplift them I like that
energy I'm buying from you
I don't not selling mine I'll steal them
from you rude
I'll I'm a size eight and a half now
I'll bind my feet I don't give a shit
your Chinese government does have some
good ideas what size were you before did
your feet grow after you got off of
birth control it's 10 it depends I'm
sometimes a 10 sometimes a ten and a
half depending on the shoes I'm wearing
but also um canceling Jimmy Choo
Christian Louboutin stopped giving money
to men that hate women and want to ruin
their feet and are already rich so
cemeteries also
um like you know chopping down wood and
killing trees to put a dead body in into
the ground it's just like it's so dumb
to me but like so non like it's weird
like I'm paying five thousand ten
thousand dollars but also unnecessary so
you know when you any Cemetery in uh a
city right
I drive my cemeteries I'm like this is
I don't think our ancestors would have
wanted us to be paying more for our
Apartments because they were taking up
real estate
why don't we free up this Cemetery
so that all of their ancestors are if
you're in your 20s now you can't even
afford a fucking to live alone yeah it's
true you can't I mean buying property
forget it but it's like our ancestors
are taken up a lot of a lot a lot of
them had slaves let's go dig them up I
mean let's go let's just maybe stack
them
somewhere and so that if to me if you
get rid of there's like five huge New
York City cemeteries if you turn those
into
either housing areas or public parks or
whatever
the rent would go down at least a little
I think a little bit but then what are
we going to do just toss everybody in a
burner
and how high are we going to go not our
problem to solve I'm just like it might
be I
okay well Marianne Williamson that one's
for you
she's not the president
Biden you can take that one who's our
president it's I what's going on I could
and by the way that's the other thing I
think I'm you know how
um kids wear in in foster homes they hit
their head against walls
no is that a thing because they just
want to feel something solid
we all need to feel like we're on Solid
Ground and I feel like America is flying
through space in a way that is like we
keep thinking like it's almost
at
uh breaking point and it's just like not
even close yeah it's it's like uh we're
at the precipice of a Breaking Point
over and over like a fully like I think
like a war possibly I think we're in it
yeah we're in it already just looks I
think silent War Holocaust still
happening just looks different slavery
is still happening just look yeah it
just looks different War's still
happening it's just germ and it's all
cyclical mind and um instead of taking
native land and using people for coal
mining Sinclair Oil Purdue whatever
they're taking our data yeah they're
mining our data it's like all this it's
all the same words that's right in front
of us right it's just done a little
different mining data mining it's all
stealing yep you know but like but if I
use Facebook it's free
like I want to go to paid social I'd
rather pay five dollars
then give you my um all my data
I agree like I would love a Char a
Google that's I pay 10 bucks a month and
there's something uh associated with
like there being a premium when people
pay money they value it a little bit
more can I tell you something really
weird I don't really know what premium a
premium means
a premium like up can you say it again
like
um can you like an insurance premium
yeah like that's the highest that it
goes like I don't know what the word
like I've heard I know I've heard the
word a lot but I I haven't learned what
it how to use it I don't understand what
it is either and I'm gonna we're adults
we should probably know this
Haley Haley what's a premium isn't it is
it the no idea she went to BU yeah if
she doesn't know
BC girl PC
ouch
who's the other girl uh Zoe
somebody else
so do you know what a premium USC did
you wait don't tell me don't tell me
were you on the crew team at USC yes yes
how did you know that dude you spend
time do you remember that you don't
remember the fucking Scandal I wasn't on
the parents paying money to the coaches
to get their kids in Felicity Huffman
that's right William and Lori from Full
House Lori Laughlin um Becky from Full
House yep Lori Laughlin Aunt Becky when
did Becky become such an ins I love that
Becky is like an insult like Becky with
the good hair like Becky and Karen yep
if that's your name you're just you're
done I have a sister Karen cr-y okay
what's your middle name Ariane I have no
idea
don't know I I need to sleep at night
too many too many things to know what
see that's the thing once your parents
die now you have time to be like hey sis
what's your middle name you know maybe I
will maybe I will find out more about
her when my dad died we kind of all went
our my sister Emily and I are very tight
but my other ones that you were just
staying at her house the one that hangs
the wreaths yes in all the rooms yeah
yes a lot of wreaths we have a lot of
Christmas wreaths by the way for um
girls that live alone
um don't feel safe in your apartment
keep a Christmas wreath on it year round
why because it makes people think that
you have Christmas parties every day
crazy okay that's a fair or just have
like every woman is a bunch of animals
women are like that's true but you can't
always have parakeets and dogs because
the lord of the land that's right the
Lord might be allergic I'm here to
collect to your service dog don't mind
my my Cool Water cologne I had a jump
where I put it well that's a tragedy I
just want to have like a little bit of
this this weed because I like I'm
will you get that blood diamond away
what is this is this a real diamond it's
a ruby and that but yeah it's very 90s
um yeah yeah
where did you get this from so am I
though yeah I'm saying I'm very 90s same
yeah I told you like someone gave it to
me to meet and greet
and were they on one knee or why no I
mean I'm the one that's on hands and
music my fucking and put my meet and
Grace I'm in my I'm in a fetal position
at all my meet and greets if people have
to hug me in a fetal position if you
could tell someone who because because
here's what I really don't want is for
us to be the authorities on dying
parents so that every time people see us
in public they're like hey my mom's and
and you're like it's happening on my
dating apps wait no no no no no no
no no
you don't get to do this to me you go
find the information yourself it's
available yeah or just like listen to
this don't you pass yeah this listen to
this one so what we say now is when
someone says my mom just went to nursing
home you go oh I uh Jesse May and I
record a podcast about it everything you
need to know is in it yeah listen to
that I'm not gonna you're not gonna make
me relive my shit because you're going
through what everyone else goes through
I don't work for you I'm not your
personal assistant that's a boundary
check your boundaries and by the way
like
if I if I give you advice it might not
apply to your situation it's all very uh
individualized you have experience you
have to connect your gut to know what's
right I can't say do what I did and move
your mom to 15 nursing homes over 12
years I don't recommend that but that's
what I did
you know well it's all like you you just
you're in it and you're surviving and
you look backwards and you've realized
you and I was figured out doing what she
told me to do because she was the parent
I'm like she's like I want to live in DC
you're my friends I'm like great let's
move into DC 20 round later it's like
this place is a nightmare and it's 15
000 a month and they don't even fucking
brush your teeth or bathe okay so great
it's so expensive to die
it's so expensive to be sick in this
country it's so expensive and the the
thing that's most frustrating about it
is
the level you need to be at as an
individual financially in order to give
your parents an iota of good care
it's which is why they need to care for
themselves yes I agree I you know the
country you live in you have no yes we
agree but we also need to have breaking
the cycle institutions but also until we
do
avoid
get ahead of it yeah and prepare and and
by the way think forward and go out in
the sun and get vitamin D and take your
fucking athletic greens and stop
drinking Coke and eating garbage it
really isn't a lot of stuff that you
have to do but a lot of people food I
think probably how does that not grow
cancer it must what GMO food oh for sure
right anything processed but anything
genetically modified the whole thing is
they do they make it it's like taking
when people take uh HGH like it's just
gonna make the cancer and you duplicate
faster yeah it'll definitely give you a
more susceptibility to it I think at
least that's what I've Pat if you were a
joint that I had taken out where would
you be in your laptop
scene
this is the
where is that we haven't found the
laptop
oh that's probably even found it talked
about it
um oh I got this one
um oh great uh I like put it it's like I
don't really want to smoke a lot of weed
I just like want like is this a strip
club
no that's Angeline who's Angeline I
don't know
um so if I'm let's say I'm 25 and I'm um
your husband your future husband's
little sister so you're gonna give me
you're gonna give me a little bit
right you're 25 and you're my future
husband's little sister yes
just got it okay okay so it's strange I
got it so Jesse hey
fuck half brother shit um no okay fuck
yeah see okay got it I got it I got it
what I got it okay dog walker so give me
something
lunch lady
that what is that lunch lady yeah they
know everything they sure do they
fucking know everything go go ahead come
here if you have questions about what
the fuck's going on at your kid's school
Luanne was my lunch lady she had big old
glasses that hung right here thick thick
glasses and shoes to give you all the
dirt on everybody all right I got it go
so I'm Leanne Kreischer
and forget the truth of what goes on
with her
uh calls you hey Jessie so sorry to
bother you
um my mom just had a stroke uh or has to
go to the hospital and possibly a
nursing home
I really don't want to waste your time
but just
three
pieces of just wait what would you say
how can I help oh let me know what I can
do yeah I would say okay what's going on
how can I help you okay so great I don't
want you to help me I just I I don't
want to take up too much your time I
just like do you have like
three pieces of advice that I wouldn't
have heard of because I've never been in
the situation just three like three and
that's it that's all yes please fuck off
bye
I can't get time for this I'm not gonna
relive my trauma I know but no no I know
we're saying it now yeah so that anytime
someone asks you direct them here so
like three things that like I wouldn't
know to even know
when someone's dying if someone's gonna
go into the hospital
that you need to take care of yourself
first
make sure that you are taking care of
your own health make sure you're you
have to put on your oxygen mask before
you you've got to put your oxygen mask
on First and in being the hero doesn't
save anybody in in the moment
and if you show up hungry angry lonely
tired and cranky you're just gonna be
mean to the person that's dying yes
two be prepared to disappoint people and
learn to be okay with that that the
people that mind don't matter and the
people that matter don't mind yes
how about this prepare to lose some
friends Prepare To Lose Friends but
prepare to find sisters and and people
you did not know could be and would be
there for you in a way that you did not
or could not have ever anticipated well
you frankly used to think we're like
weirdos yeah they I lost friends and I
gained lifetime family members
awesome three
this one's kind of cheesy
um
but
I think
figure out a way to make connections
with your family and figure out a way if
it's safe for you if it's safe for you
but figure out a way to
um once it didn't molest you you know
well maybe maybe we can
you know figure that out as well no wait
um I want to really think about this
okay
I would say three
and it doesn't have to be perfect if you
have four that's fine too I just want to
waste your time
I think
really realize that
there can be Silver Linings in the chaos
and the sadness and and try to be open
to that
I think maybe that
edited would be
okay with letting go
and to maybe add to that if this applies
to you
don't worry about having a sense of
humor no like if something funny happens
like when I was kind of smoking a joint
I'm trying to like see if my mom wanted
to smoke a joint and she was kind of
like trying and it like didn't really
work and then I just took like a hit and
like
I did sort of Ash on her shoulder
and like
like she would have wanted me to laugh
and I I got it off I mean she's about to
look like that so I was like okay
I mean let's just why even why even
brush it off you know so it's like to be
able to just like you're not an asshole
if you make a sick joke you're not it's
just like we all cope differently I
totally cope and cut tension with humor
it's not for everyone no it's not people
might think it's inappropriate but find
the people that do know your heart so
that you can grieve the way you need to
grieve and the way I need to grieve
sometimes is making a bunch of fucking
jokes yes I agree you know and like and
don't and don't beat yourself up if
you're not grieving the way you saw in
the changeling like not everyone has to
grieve like you've seen in the movies
yeah grieving is
um very personal and
you know so amazing things happen when
you share what you're going through I
talked about this before you know John
Heffron love also I think people take
turns in the family so we're sisters
four
you're crying all day today I got to be
strong today tomorrow I'll fall apart
like we I think that someone's like why
are you crying It's like because you are
and then I'll take tomorrow I'll be able
to you know what I mean yeah you got to
be flexible and just go with the flow of
the emotions
um John Heffron reached out to me and
said something that changed my life
he told me when my dad would not be a
comedian yeah and I I'm here
um denouncing comedy but I also started
a religion
uh
you are going to be mad I'm gonna be so
so rich
um he sent me a message because his I
think his mother had had Alzheimer's and
he's not by the way I have that did you
go through that that was my dad had
that's right that vascular dementia but
yeah it's a you know a form of dementia
and Alzheimer's is the most common hey
scientists stop working about on how to
make men stronger and fix that seriously
that part
um well there's not money in prevention
there's more money in yours because that
means a disease has to exist and half
the scientists right now are telling us
to sleep eight hours a night I'm like I
got it yeah cool we got it
get to work on other stuff hey can let's
use all Epstein's money that was given
to all the colleges to just for
Alzheimer's and then we're good yeah
um or not he reached out and he was like
just know that one of the final senses
to go is hearing
like you you retain your hearing that's
the belief at least to the end and so he
said you know keep talking to your dad
even though he's not responding he can
hear
and that that kind of changed things for
me because I was always so afraid to
talk to him towards the end because he
wasn't communicative so it felt like I
was just having it one way fingers or
something yeah not having a conversation
so it was hard to do that with somebody
who I had built and had this amazing
relationship with and I don't want to
say all this stuff
um like without you yeah and I like it
would hurt too much to know you can't
hear it anyway right
you know and to not know that you could
hear it you know towards the end with my
dad when John Heffron sent me that
message I wrote on my mirror call your
father because I was so afraid to call
him because I didn't know if he was
going to be able to understand
and that message stayed there for a long
time and I wrote it because of John
Heffron and I thought that you said
father too there's a difference there's
a big difference something happens when
your parents get sick they stop being
your dad and mom and they start being
her mother and father yeah it's
interesting weird
maybe it's a form of it's like a respect
respect real like you get performance
the alpha is past the out that's The
Changing of the Guard it's a changing of
the alpha yep and I don't think our
parents go until they know you're ready
to replace them if
if they
are fighting
I wholeheartedly agree Maybe
I think it's the same way where we want
to receive love they want to give it and
I think it goes back to that
conversation of the will to live and
what is
what is keeping someone out here on
Earth when there's other forces pulling
them because sometimes they want to get
out of their kids way and not you know
but like my mom 11 days no feeding tube
which by the way hospice how do they die
no one tells you this
it's horrible
dehydration
not starvation
because feeding actually
creates more energy because you have to
digest it and then they'll die faster so
if you feed that it's so
counterintuitive because you're like how
do I you know so and then she's like I'm
thirsty and you're like but
you're dehydrating so you can only use
like a fucking sponge yep we had to do
that too like it's just like a nightmare
and you're like just sitting there like
not like letting someone die it's just
like it's so wide it's like dude it will
change you forever it does change you in
a way that is like
like someone can text me and be like do
you want to go for a hike and I'll just
like no thanks
five years ago I'd be like yeah sure
when you make the plan knowing I'm Gonna
Cancel and like that's kind of I guess
we'll just invite them to comic stores
because the hiker you know I'll go now I
could just tell them like none of it
yeah you you it prioritizes your the way
you step into the world you get real
decisive real clear you do get very very
clear I used to spend a lot of time like
trying to make decisions and it's
important I think
uh one of the things that changed my
life was that John Heffron sending me
that message and also my brother-in-law
saying you know without with our father
who wasn't communicative at the end he
said you know I think he's hanging on I
think your father is hanging on and I
think
this is the hardest
thing I have ever had to say in my life
and I've said a lot of fucking crazy
shit I've done a lot of crazy shit and
I've said so many inappropriate things
and difficult things this is the hardest
thing I ever had to say and I think it
will go down as the most difficult thing
I ever had to say to my dad and it was
you can go I'm the most beautiful
daughter you have no
which doesn't explain so why didn't you
molest me
I my brother-in-law said I think you
need to let him know and we were all in
the room with my dad and my dad wasn't
even showing any sort of non
um verbal communication nothing wasn't
communicating with us and Ice we were
all there and I said to him I said Dad
we're loved
we are okay we're happy
and you can go
and he started to cry that connected
with him he was waiting to hear that
yeah because he was fucking hanging on
he needed you guys to tell him we had to
tell him good like we're fine even
through his dementia there was a part of
him that was just like scratching to
hang on to hear that
and from that point he declined very
fast uh same with my mom
um
11 days no
um
feeding tube and they're just like what
the fuck I mean by eight days and my
sister she's older she's we just have a
completely different
skill set but it are so complementary
but we have a really fraught like family
drama like we come from like Hatfield
and McCoy like people like we come from
like
family members that like pull shotguns
on each other like it's like we come
from that shit like it's just like we
just this motherfucker like what like
um found the episode sound bite
if we come from a family it pulls
shotguns like we just do like it's just
that shit so it's like
um and my sister is like so much braver
than me I mean I think it seems like I'm
brave because we like talk to strangers
for a living it's the least Brave thing
ever I mean we have security guards like
they pay us like for like you know I
mean if you're if you're a younger
female comic now it's very dangerous
like it's very dangerous to be a comic
right now female comic or I mean if
you're not I mean Chris Rock was punched
in the face like no one stood up like no
one cared yeah wild like Dave Chappelle
likes a knife machete like no like
people they thought it was like funny
like um but my sister did say to her and
I got mad at her my sister was like Mom
like you can go whenever you're ready
like we're okay and I'm like
like I was just like
like I couldn't
like wrap my head around her thinking
like that we wanted her to die
but like we had also worked so hard to
keep her along alive for so long and she
had asked to die so many times and then
my sister and I were like you know just
reuniting like because that's the thing
is when I would add to your list of
things
be prepared
to be in uh 20 by 20 room with all your
siblings and family members that you
have beef with
for two months straight and be prepared
be prepared for that beef to resurface
they'll be at their worst ever you you
meet everybody at their worst when
you're going through this absolutely
yeah and you will show your worst as
well and it might and it might not be
your work it might be what needs to
happen at that time yes and it's honest
whatever you're feeling I had a family
member show up at my dad's funeral in
shorts and Crocs I'm sorry about that
and I grabbed their by the face
and I said sped out the gum
and you can go sit in the car
or you can sit cross style behind
everyone well that's rude because I was
working on quitting smoking and it was
Nicorette now dare you grab me by the
cheek
so then my sit my mom's wish was my
sister and Ida like
like reunite even though we were torn
apart by all the family you know
alcoholism in order for alcoholism to be
present alcohol doesn't have to be
present
and um so we were in the house with her
we were downstairs and we were doing
great but then we would like fight about
something that was just like how sisters
like I've also have it in my sister in
my life like I don't even know how I'm
so conflict avoidant and I'm so
foreign
actively uh proactive about not having
girlfriends or people in my life women
that are catty like I just it's it's
it's fine it's just not for me I just
don't like that kind of conflict I I I
want to fight with Scientology face to
face on a boat I don't want to like do
some like hey hey with a female comic in
hallway I just I
I'm sure I'm not above it it just like
doesn't get me off conflict-wise so I
shut down
and my sister like is so to me like
she's like a celebrity to me because
she's my big sister and like she was
like I was her little like she was just
like you know has always just been on
such a pedestal for me so when I feel
like
and she communicates like very clearly
and I sometimes like need a second to
like I'm the same choose my words and
she interprets it it's like why are you
know it's like we're just like re-
meeting each other so we would like
fight like fucking dogs over
some bullshit because the hospice guy
came over
so I leave for like 10 minutes
to go get stuff from the house to bring
like oils and stuff for her we're like
oiling her up with her favorite oils and
like lip balms so I like went back to my
place like feed my dogs the hospice guy
comes finally
he's six hours late my mom has not had
any drugs she's completely sober and has
no idea what's going on the hospice guy
comes in and we're looking good the
hospice guy is going to like handle this
you know and he comes and he goes hello
Patty so you know you're dying right
my sister was in there alone I wasn't
there
not that I mean whatever
so you'll be dying here the feeding
tube's been out if she doesn't know any
of this and there were no drugs even
giving up I mean I feel like that's a
conversation where you need to be on
some psilocybin I mean just at the
minimum just whatever I don't know I
don't feel like a turkey I don't know
how that was supposed to be handled but
I don't think it was that way I think he
could have come over to me or my sister
going hey so you know I'll I'll does she
know she's dying does she know this does
she know this yeah I'm about to scream
in your mom's ear that she's dying is
that cool by the way she has perfect
hearing why are you even yelling
who trained you
[Music]
interesting sorry well we know it's not
your birth control so then sorry and
then we'll wrap up and we'll do this
again a million times but um
so then my sister and I
like after like seven days we were just
like right back to being this like
well-boiled machine and like cooking and
like she you know I knew what she wanted
to eat and then I would go like we were
just like working together like as a
team and that's when my mom died
she needed to know that my sister and I
could sustain and then I uh
it's just so wild and it like shouldn't
be emotional because it's just so like
nature but like
she wasn't dying she wasn't dying and I
was like why not what does she need what
does she need to know that she can go
because she can't really do anything
here
you know what I mean she's been like
can you imagine like watching your
daughter's suffer and like not being
able to do anything about it like it's
just like it's like that movie Revenant
when he was his kid was you know getting
murdered and he was like listening to it
like it's just like
I just can't I can't fathom it um
and so I had and then toward the end you
can only talk to her for a minute at a
time
why was that a minute because if you do
more you're gonna you have to let the
heart rate will go up and if she gets
excited and you're she's gonna die
because she's excited and it shouldn't
be that she should die naturally like
the idea in hospice is you get out of
the way in the hospice
worker she's the boss she tells you you
can talk to her now for a minute
you're out like she's in charge because
families left her their own devices will
be like oh Bob and that stresses them
out yep and then they're gonna die
faster and they're dying of stress not
natural causes you know what I mean
absolutely it's like but then I talked
about the hospice program I'm like but
you've seen a lot of shit she's like
I've had guns pulled on me I mean it's
like you know
um because people want a lot of people
want their families last dying words to
be you get the house or whatever right
you know what I mean so it's like fucked
up people sneak in and we'll make you
sign shit when you're dying like wild
chick goes not
so dying brings out the truth
so um
I'm talking to my sisters like
downstairs and my sister's been like you
know we've just been estranged in a lot
of ways and
um as you've uh aptly you mentioned like
medical care it's a nightmare so it's
like she's you know she's a really big
yoga instructor but it's like she's like
between health insurance whatever and um
and I just like sat on her bed this was
like one in the morning or something and
um
so I had just started getting my sister
because she's going to start future me
yoga she's like I need it's like I need
to start doing it I'm such a brat for
like never stretching and um
so I just set her up with my
gynecologist to get mammogram bracha
test
um some bad dental work like all these
fucking fillings we got 25 years ago oh
yeah they're causing dementia dude but
taking them out is also the the is it
Mercury could get so you have to take it
out very carefully yes if you're
removing these old cavities sometimes
it's safer just leaving I don't I don't
know you guys told me I got all those
taken out so I told
um smart I told uh my mom I was just
like I need to apologize that's what she
needs to hear because by the way oh
remember why I don't change my phone
number because I don't want to take the
risk of an ex calling to apologize and
be missing it oh that's a solid answer
solid reason stand by it they could
reach me otherwise but I'm not never
changing my number so I just started
blathering
I was just like okay Mom I'm so sorry
that I spilled nail polish remover on
your
um fucking Chester drawers those nice
gestures because I remember her like
getting so upset and being like well who
care like it was like a lacquer finish
I'm sorry that I called you a hooker
when I was 11. not sorry and you
do it again you hit me well it's right
here I should have said sex worker
um I'm sorry I called you a hooker but
thank you for slapping me in the face
after I did
thank you right that changed the course
of my life yep thank you for all my
Christmases being the gay men that you
work with at Neiman Marcus my gay
Christmas because
I was in danger around straight men gay
ones are the ones I felt safe around
blah blah blah and then I just went oh
my God I have to
[Music]
my sister has an appointment
with my gynecologist on Monday at 11.
and
um Dental appointments to fix all the
mess next week she has surgery next week
at whatever day it was so basically you
told your mom you're fixing all your
sister's holes I'm not I'm not
yeah I'm not fake I'm just that she's
has Medical Care and then she died
I was saying I wasn't saying in that
moment
I mean
pretty suit I mean
the next day morning at like
I don't know no it was I guess there's
heart stopped the next day at like three
you know 11 days I mean it's a lot of
it's a lot of fucking time maybe that's
not why maybe that's just something I
need to believe like no I I know I think
you're not who the meaning is what it is
for you and I I think having talked to a
lot of people about this point of life
where people are facing death I think
people need to hear things I think they
need something
to release that will to live because
everyone I think really wants besides
people who are suffering I know your
mother was suffering there's still a
desire to stay
I think as long as she knew the same way
your dad
if your dad knew that you were okay with
him going
like I think ultimately he's like I
don't want to disappoint you guys and
leave so soon I'm just like it's just
like it's just so um
it just makes me so mad that but their
parents were in Wars so like what the
fuck do they know like we're the first
generation that can even get ahead of
this like we're the first we are with
any foresight so it's just like with
some hope to being able to deal with
this without with some dignity and with
preparation and without it bankrupting I
think In Our Lifetime we will see laws
around like you cannot have kids without
a living will you cannot have kids
without medical directives you can't
have like you just can't it I wouldn't
by the way you can't call an ambulance
for someone
unless they need it that's an eight
thousand dollar bill I'm crawling back
in the house you know don't try to help
me no I'm good I realize that my arm is
off
says yes call the ambulance or no call
two blinks says yes one is no I realize
I'm just a torso and a head at this
point but do not call the ambulance you
come by the way what can we do a
screening of Boxing Helena
I don't know what that is but if you got
pizza I'll I'll come
more pizza I'll do anything for pizza
oh God is it not something can we go to
Hillary Clinton's Clinton's pizza
restaurant God
um okay it's been many hours I love you
more than anything I love you too thank
you for doing this I feel like we cried
the whole time I feel like this really
humanized us
if only we weren't acting crying
I feel like this isn't going to open up
a lot of doors well not our parents
bedroom because no one's in there
because they're dead
too soon
Karen's bedroom oh you were one of those
Rich bitches with a house well parents
had their own bedroom we had four houses
because the family broke up so many
times
we did a World Tour on Christmas because
there were so many Ex-Wives and
stepsisters and half-sisters I felt like
a zoom
okay feels like a zoom yeah true
we're done
oh I am these very awkwardly did you
kiss my mom's forehead
no should I you kissed her forehead
you know what I told you I was gonna
bring the pillow
no it's okay every time I put something
down like it's probably where the joint
is like weird I'm like like I'm feeling
a little scatterbrained I think it's
because I'm in like Flow State like I'm
feeling very like reflux I see something
I want to get
don't touch my shit did you say it oh
that's for you actually just don't open
it in front of the mic you haven't said
it
oh
I'll give it to you in a second hey um
what don't we ride
what don't we ride
broke guys dicks
is that the wrong answer
don't ride baby elephants oh same thing
don't ride elephants we love you bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]